god i'm so sorry i'm sorry just tuned
in some serious couples counseling
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my venom
let there be carnage trailer video there's a whole
bunch of new footage in easter eggs so we'll break
it all down if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos there are
even more spider-man easter eggs so we'll talk
about that too i know everybody's still wondering
where the spider-man no way home trailer is more
like spider-man no way we're getting that trailer
but the whole idea here is that we're just getting
a way better look at the carnage symbiote and
they're hyping up way more of their relationship
like he says to me eddie your family as in
literally family because carnage is the spawn of
the venom symbiote they also pretty much explain
how he gets the carnage symbiote is a slight twist
on the comic book origin for carnage venom still
seems like he spawns it just seems like from the
events of the trailer he basically bites eddie
and ingests some of his blood but his blood has
been mixed with the venom symbiote and so it's
eddie's blood with the venom symbiote mixing
with cletus cassidy's blood that then causes
it to spawn into the carnage symbiote it feels
like they've also polished a lot of the special
effects since they released that last big trailer
but starting at the beginning of the trailer going
through shot by shot they start with him on the
ducati out in the countryside his motorcycle
helmet is red and black carnage theme sort of
foreshadowing the big twist that's coming up the
way the andy circus the director explained their
relationship when the movie picks up is that as
you can see in the trailer the venom symbiote is
frustrated he's saying i'm a predator we should be
out there eating bad guys but eddie brock doesn't
want to have any of that he's like no no you can't
eat people even though they made the bargain at
the end of the first movie you can only eat bad
people it's almost as if he's pulling back on that
in the venom symbiote just getting really really
frustrated when he's saving this person from what
seems like a mugger it's hard to tell when this
is happening it could be a little bit earlier in
the film so it's meant to show you that he still
is eating a couple bad people here and there but
not nearly as many as the venom symbiote probably
wants to i don't know why this tire says snooki on
it some sort of weird jersey shore reference we
go to the ravencroft institute obviously a big
place from the spider-man comics it's also the
same place during the amazing spider-man andrew
garfield films where they ended that film teasing
the big sinister six reveal where harry osborne in
that franchise was creating a new version of the
sinister six back at oscorp there's a rumor that
we might see a version of oscorp sometime in the
next couple of big spider-man spin-off movies so
we'll see but the whole idea is that ravencroft
is where cletus cassidy's girlfriend so to speak
shriek is being held but you can clearly see that
she's either a mutant or a metahuman we'll see
how they explain that during the movie i haven't
heard them talk too much about that she does have
special powers very clearly later in the trailer
you also see her use her abilities to basically
smash the whole front of the car off in the
windshield shriek was a big part of the maximum
carnage storylines so you can see they're adapting
some of maximum carnage for this first story of
venom versus carnage i was always hoping they were
going to do a version of that in the movies at
some point but because it wasn't totally clear how
they're going to involve the spider-man character
even though a lot of spider-man easter eggs now
it's hard to tell how much maximum carnage they're
going to be doing because maximum carnage was
not carnage's origin story you kind of built up
to that and the whole idea was is that during
that storyline spider-man and venom teamed up
to take down carnage so this sort of explains how
things go so crazy once cletus cassidy ingests
his blood and gets a taste of the venom symbiote
and why the venom symbiote reacts the way it does
when it bonds with cletus cassidy is like the
purest expression of what it's asking for here
just be completely free free from all the logic
that's tying eddie down the fact that he wants to
be a normal person and exist in the world with
other people then later in the trailer you see
them have a sort of renaissance as carnage
has manifested like okay now you can eat
anybody you want because things have gone so crazy
we need to take out all these bad guys the whole
thing with the cletus cassidy plot though like
it seems like he knows more about what's going
on with eddie in the symbiote than he lets on i
think that he's just a little obsessed with eddie
brock as this reporter and as a serial killer
he just craves that attention from the media
and i think the idea was that earlier eddie brock
had been writing all these articles about him that
helped him get put in prison so their relationship
goes back way before the events of the first film
but the story that he's talking about giving
eddie i want to give you my story he wants
to tell eddie about all these other bodies that
the police never found that he hid all over the
place as you can see them digging up what seems
like some of those bodies here on this beach
you notice the notes the cletus cassidy the
drawings he's been sending to eddie it says
to the strife has been given between the suffering
there's a little heart on the tree then there's a
drawing of the church that it seems like they're
fighting at later in the movie he also knows that
certain frequencies sonic weapons are deadly
against the venom symbiotes so they might use
a similar twist as the venom origin story with the
church bells to try and stop cletus cassidy or at
least hamstring him during this movie eddie brock
seems like he's writing this article for the daily
bugle so obviously a big spider-man reference but
it's the daily bugle logo from the tobey maguire
spider-man movies we know the morbius movie is a
direct spin-off of the venom movies and it's going
to be happening right after this movie early next
year during that trailer we saw a very notable
tobey mcguire spider-man costume i've already
explained how the director andy circus said that
during the events of this movie cletus cassidy
eddie brock detective mulligan the toxin character
from the comics who seems like he's working
with eddie brock as part of this big article
that he's writing on cletus cassidy have no idea
are not aware of the existence of a spider-man
that doesn't mean that spider-man doesn't exist
on this earth but we just had the loki series we
just had that big twist with kang in the true
version of the multiverse being unleashed so i
will address that because there is an easter
egg that seems like it's sort of hinting at
that towards the end of the trailer i've already
done a couple videos about how the sony executives
the president of sony pictures have explained
how they do have a plan for connecting all this
and it'll basically be laid bare like they'll
explain everything during spider-man no way home
which based on some of the stuff we've learned
about the movie seems like it contains a lot of
spider-verse multiverse elements that are based
on what happened at the end of the loki series
cletus cassidy says what's mine is yours and
what's yours is mine as he literally bites him
and basically takes essentially takes the carnage
symbiote for himself although that's not exactly
the way it goes down he takes his blood which
is laced with the venom symbiote then the venom
symbiote spawns like it does in the comics and
that creates the carnage symbiote the change that
they made from the comic book origin story for
carnage is that they were actually cellmates the
venom symbiote came and busted eddie brock out
but while it was rescuing eddie it spawned left
behind a piece of itself that piece bonded with
cletus cassidy in that form the carnage symbiote
so here eddie's kind of leaving a piece of that
symbiote behind but not because it's spawned it's
because cletus cassidy literally bit him and
ingested his blood the other interesting thing
here you'll note is that he's wearing that white
prison jumpsuit the same white prison jumpsuit
that michael keaton's version of the vulture
is wearing during the morbius trailer so i'm
wondering if the prison where they're getting
ready to execute cletus cassidy here later in
the movie because the color of prison jumpsuit is
different is the same place where vulture scorpion
and then morbius are going to show up during
the morbius movie like i don't think it's a
coincidence that he's in a white prison jumpsuit
here when they're getting ready to execute him
on death row but it seems like he doesn't have any
idea what's going on with a carnage symbiote until
it manifests bursts out of him literally while
they're in the middle of executing him i like the
way they foreshadow this too because right before
it happens you see eddie flip his visor down and
it's a red helmet he has red stripes going down
the back just foreshadowing the carnage twist
it kind of seems like by this point of the movie
they actually have gone to new york city so
it seems like that's the connection to spider-man
homecoming the vulture and those sinister six
characters then there's this huge battle that
seems like they have in this church getting
very biblical also a lot of references back to the
venom origin story with spider-man and the church
bells if you're not a big comic book reader there
was also this whole thing with the cult of carnage
during the marvel comics too and we get our full
carnage reveal and because of the way they color
correct this you get a slightly better look at
what he actually looks like in broad daylight
he's not quite as bright red as he is in the
comics but i think they just want to have a little
more parody with the venom symbiote everybody use
your family guy memes because he totally says the
name of the movie inside the trailer all i want
in this life is carnage oh he said the thing
the thing with carnage's powers that are a little
bit different from venom is he's much quicker to
manifest weapons using the symbiote whereas the
venom symbiote doesn't do that quite as much
this is a much more special effects of him
breaking out a prison you see a little bit
better how the symbiote works like they literally
fire a giant hole through his chest that the
symbiote just closes up instantly they just want
to hype up how op and almost unkillable carnage is
going to be the idea that eddie brock could be
way more powerful with the venom symbiote than
he's letting himself be because he's holding back
so hard this is cletus cassidy after he's become
carnage breaking his girlfriend shriek out of
ravencroft then whatever happens during the
film maybe because the article that eddie writes
about him or something in that article he swears
revenge on him i also think originally eddie was
responsible for getting him put in prison in the
first place like way back before the events of
the first film so that's the connection back to
anne wang's character who is back for the sequel
they did tease that they would be doing more lady
venom stuff during this like she would also wear
the symbiote again at some point during the film
but we don't get a ton from her in this trailer
and it seems that she's about to get married to
her doctor boyfriend from the first film they play
that mostly for comedy in the venom symbiote not
being able to deal with that that should be us
getting married to her i love this scene here too
when the venom symbiote sees the karna symbiote
for the first time and reacts to it oh that's a
red one it just seems like it doesn't immediately
understand the relationship between it and carnage
like eventually it will understand oh that came
from me that's sort of like my spawn that's like
my child essentially the relationship between the
different symbiotes is kind of funny like carnage
eventually spawns the toxin symbiote and that
bonds with detective mulligan who's a character
during this so maybe they'll tease that for future
sequels they'll eventually do the toxin symbiote
but the carnage symbiote hates the toxin symbiote
like it hates its own spawn and wants to kill it
when cletus cassidy says eddie you feel like
home to me that's just another reference to the
relationship between the venom symbiote and the
carnage symbiote the scene of cletus cassidy
kicking this bodega owner it's hard to tell where
this is happening if it's in new york city if it's
back in san francisco there's a couple more scenes
of him breaking out a prison of him breaking
shriek out of ravencroft we get a bunch more
scenes of the carnage symbiote just manifesting
you see it just looking around the way it's going
to visualize during the film is way wilder way
more fluid looking than the venom symbiote and
during a couple scenes in the trailer they do
show you license plates and usually when they show
you a license plate it is a comic book reference
to something but i can't really detect any big
comic book easter eggs for eddie's license plate
on his bike but at the end of the trailer on their
car here on the license plate it reads 65 1965 was
actually a big year for marvel comics that's the
same year that kang the conqueror debuted or he
debuted as king the conqueror but the whole idea
is that kang the conqueror is going to be the new
big main overarching villain of the mcu in marvel
phase 4 like the new thanos level villain that
feels like it's a subtle wink at what happened
at the end of the loki series with the multiverse
kang war that they're using for the plot of
spider-man no way home the big multiverse plot
spider-verse plot and they'll be using that same
logic to explain how spider-man can eventually
cross over with the venom movies and how
everything is connected between the sony marvel
movies the venom movies in the mcu marvel movies
with tom hall and spider-man like everything is
suddenly canon now because of what loki and silvie
did at the loki finale thank you very much sylvie
but i'm not expecting a ton of big references
to that during the events of venom let there
be carnage i think the way the sony executive
explained it is mostly spider-man no way home
where they're going to be explaining how that's
all going to work so that might be why they're
holding off so much on the trailer for that just
because they're not quite ready to explain how
that's going to work i also did a video a little
while ago where kevin feige was talking about
putting venom inside the mcu but because of what
they did with the loki series it sounds like now
kevin feige is much more open to introducing
venom into the mcu proper at some point if you
spotted any big easter eggs that i didn't talk
about during the trailer just write them below
in the comments and i will do more venom videos as
we get more footage from the movie next week the
marvel what if episodes are starting i will be
doing full episode videos for all those so make
sure you have alerts enabled for that it'll also
be trading heavily on the multiverse themes of
what happened at the end of the loki series will
you wait for everything click here for my brand
new marvel shang chi trailer video in easter eggs
to learn how it's connected to the iron man movies
and click here for my new loki video about the
connection between iron man and kang the conqueror
in the mcu thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next video!